et bien faire un bisou
ouais je suis chiant viens me faire un
bisou
c'est quel étage merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rien de Chine 42 ça c'est
maman c'est surtout ma mère qui est là
qui est dans la vie une vierge tu peux
l'avoir même si ça te fait bizarre mais
elle est là et je suis très fier quand
la film ce soir elle est là
ah ouais ouais
ici c'est elle qui me l'a demandé c'est
un sujet toujours fait elle vit avec moi
et c'est génial elle a jamais été aussi
présente dans ma vie tu sais maman est
tibétaine elle est née à ça et elle est
arrivée à la frontière
indochinoise quand tous les
après avoir eu toute ma famille
massacrée par les Chinois
et puis moi je suis là le bonheur de
naître de sortir du ventre de ma mère
quand
[Musique]
elle m'a mis au monde là-bas
voilà et c'est c'était déjà demandé de
garder ses cendres
toujours oui toujours et j'ai tous ces
objets c'est elle elle est dans la vie
vierge comme elle pouvait être là-bas
elle a ses objets elle a même les
peoples parce qu'elle fumait sur mon
bureau tu vois ah ouais
voilà
[Musique]
moitié indochinois moitié français non
je suis moitié tibétain parce que maman
est tibétaine
je te le redis et papa était de Brive
mais d'un grand-père américain de Dallas
le Dallas aux États-Unis et puis bon
voilà
et puis ce mur c'est ma vie quoi c'est
une apparte de ma vie tous tout ce que
j'ai pu
tout ce que j'ai pu
il y a des tout ce que tu as appris tu
l'as écrit sur ce mur tu as ressentiment
ça c'est un mot
crier manifester marché à prendre à
parler
et après c'est aller plus loin mais il
la passe il l'a pas repris dans je vais
pas mis c'est à dire connaître les
différences dépasser les insolences
aller plus loin et porter les couleurs
de l'enfance parce que moi je les porte
depuis toujours
et la tristesse brûle mes yeux
[Musique]
mon cœur est gris mon cœur
est bleu je ne pourrais pas être heureux
[Musique]
je n'ai pas
quelqu'un
qui me dit
je t'aime
non je n'ai pas
trouver
quelqu'un qui me dit je t'aime
t'aime
[Musique]
et la vérité c'est que j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un en a
[Musique]
je voudrais bien qu'elle vienne à côté
de moi mais bon
et bien me faire un bisou et quoi
un bisou
je suis chiant viens me faire un bisou
c'est incroyable quoi
[Musique]
voilà
ça reste là
on s'est branché tous les deux sur une
fondation sur le Tibet
maintenant disons que pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas ils vont mieux monter pour
le Tibet que pour rien du tout hein
sur le fond c'est un contrôle
avec le bouddhisme tout ça ça
m'intéresse et
donc avec des amis et donc c'est pour ça
aussi que que j'ai été plus sensible au
Tibet qu'à d'autres pays mais bon il
vaut mieux que il vaut mieux
s'intéresser à ça car rien du tout je
suis je suis pas là qu'avec ce qu'on
pense là il est vraiment sensibilisé par
ça il est c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui lui tient à cœur et et mal
connaissance je me doute que si c'est
pas le genre alors le truc de cette ça
s'appelle je sais pas me parler anglais
moi the cross camping apparemment la
campagne des croix et alors ils essayent
de photographier des gens connus
avec avec cet autocollant quoi ah oui
d'accord alors voilà
sur le front là parce que oui non non
parce que moi je tiens vraiment à ça
voilà voilà et
plus il y aura de Jésus
puis il y aura de de monde comme ça
plus ça serait important quelque part
nous on boit du champagne et quelque
part j'aimerais qu'on boivent plus de
champagne et que tout le pognon qu'on
file au champagne on le fil à ses
enfants et aux gens qui sont en train de
crever parce qu'ils sont en train de
crever quoi nous on est vraiment bien là
on se rend même pas compte et ceci dit
attention il y a pas que le Tibet il y
en a partout comme ça mais bon
ma maman est tibétaine je dis allez même
si elle est partie parce qu'elle est
près de moi elle est là elle est au fond
de mon cœur et et elle est surtout dans
dans tout ce qui habite ma vie ma maison
et tout et ça je jamais je pourrais
oublier ça et que vraiment c'est un truc
à faire c'est ça et je le ferai et si
jamais
j'aurais pas cru et ben si tu m'avais
dit était royaliste moi non plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu